welcome to the month of August in
September this is my journal slash blog
I call it a journal because it kind of
is for the month of August and in this
month of August this is the month I
actually get the projector from LG so
you see me kind of gush over it in real
time you know and LG wanted to follow up
and so in the last few minutes of this
journal entry I do a follow up and I'll
explain it when when you get there but
in the meantime welcome to the month of
August my dogs are here going nuts for
some danger you couldn't see him but he
just sat down in the most pathetic
really it's paying attention to me so I
could talk about the journal all day or
I can just show you so welcome to the
month of August let's get on with the
journal and transition with a puppy just
like get that thing away from me I would
just going to the thing Fire Emblem
three houses just got real like
next-level rail like epic Harry Potter
chapters like the most epic chapters Rio
I started watching the boys last night
that technically it was the first of
August so it'll be in this month's
journal which you already know you've
already seen it's like I'm still
speaking for July
anyhow Fire Emblem three houses get it
[ __ ] country why is YouTube rendering my
videos and standard death it's like 340
P again just like the last video I
uploaded my review for the boys that's
going live at 6 a.m. I play a little bit
of video games
it's 4:30 because my sleeping pad and
you're [ __ ] but I go over there and
it's like three 40s peed so I delete it
and then now I'm reloading it I hope
it's in high def like you the file
itself is stupid alright he's read weird
I haven't been crying it's fair but the
video is in 1080p
the second time it uploaded it so all I
have to do
going forward apparently is uploaded
video when it's done processing delete
that video and upload the video again
should be good that's really stupid so I
had I'm at a birthday hang out with Adam
went to the goose game store out of
birthday I have two tickets to
Impractical Jokers that I won't be able
to make so my cousin Christian I'm
giving them to him you can do whatever
you want with them have fun like
front-row - who's your favorite cousin
[Music]
so my cousins went to watch Impractical
Jokers last night I guess they really
had a blast it's like the fact that they
had that much fun makes it worth the
cost of what the tickets goth it's like
I started out the day being irritated if
not bummed out if not a little pissed
that I was out the cost of the tickets
but the fact that they had that much fun
there makes it worth the cost of the
tickets so I'm glad they had fun yeah
how horse played are real I'm gonna beat
the game but I'm not done cuz they got
to go back and do the other path like I
played the Black Eagles and there's a
part in that storyline where it Forks
it's like you can either go that way or
that way
so i zigged and now i'm gonna restart
the save and play it where I zag I'm
gonna see how it is the other way not
all addictions bad
[Music]
they say no one ever dies in this show
dead so LG sent me a projector that they
want me to feature in my July Journal
although this is August I'm gonna
feature at my July journal because we
tried to to get the paper work all done
by that time it just didn't work out but
they did send me a pretty sweet
projectors I want to do my solid but I
was like yeah I have a movie theater
room but it's kind of it's embarrassing
so I need to hang curtains and like put
something there for the projector to be
on it's us so here I am building that I
mean I can't lose my cred video showing
my theater screen and it looks like a
wire abomination now all right so that's
what the projector will go on and it'll
short throw under the screen and then
with the black curtains lining it those
are my black curtains it should look
pretty good so I've been staying up all
night
many nights playing Fire Emblem three
houses to the point where like this
sun's coming up and I'm going to bed so
I swear to you I bought one of these on
Amazon silly so I could sleep put it on
block up the sunlight go to sleep
because you know war is hell and we lost
a lot of good men out there Fire Emblem
so like I don't know you're on your own
YouTube's now just so you know he's a
regular human
so time flies and today's the five-year
mark of Robin Williams passing away I
can't believe it's per half a decade
like a half a decade of I would call it
a world with no Robin Williams but he
does live on this work you know since a
lot of us knew him from his work he does
live on innocence but still it's tragic
nonetheless all right so I got these
curtain rods from Ikea I have to slip
this over that and it'll line underneath
the screen son of a [ __ ] doesn't quite
touch the ground it's just it's like an
inch off so I have to order a much
longer one and then folded in I'd rather
have it too long than too short because
the white going across the bottom I'm
just gonna see it it's gonna bother me
all right
a couple more days I can get back on the
project I just woke up first order of
business after feeding my dogs is I'm on
YouTube and I'm watching Super Smash
Brothers rage quits there's something
about that game you know there's
something about that game when you lose
and Smash Brothers it's not like losing
in any other fighting game really you
know if something about how just in your
face the game is the speed the energy
that when you lose it hurts more than a
lot of other fighting games a lot of
rage quits its YouTube it it's
entertaining for days when you're really
tired and accidentally pour yourself a
bowl of cereal in dangers dog dish so I
hooked up the projector and I couldn't
have to fit the screen so I have it
because I had this which is too tall for
it because of the size of the screen so
it's literally resting on its own box so
I need to get something for it to be on
about 9 inches tall okay so there's this
thing that's left over from when Vanessa
was making bookshelves in these legs
and with the legs and that if you add it
up comes out to about 9 inches so all I
needs that platform and those screwed it
into the bottom of it I think that could
work for the projector possibly still
need a couple inches I think I could do
with that I mean it looks kind of silly
it's just so much bigger than the
platform but uh I could put the Xbox one
s underneath it and and have myself a
little smallest entertainment center
ever whatever we're limping along just
trying to get it done I didn't know I
didn't know I'd fall into a projector
that would just like come to me okay I
mean the roots a mess but we got picture
that looks really good I mean you can't
tell because my phone's not filming in
4k so this looks really good all right
black cinema curtains are all up
subwoofer really pathetic looking quote
entertainment it's just the right height
so till I get something else but I need
sound for my 7.1 surround which is why
one gets a 50-foot optical cable to go
from there to the back of the room which
is really messy so I'm not going to show
you but that looks really cool dude
noir Logan you gotta oh my god blue
planet - on Netflix it's all shot in 4k
so if you have the tech I highly
recommend it it's it's like you're there
projectionists jeremy has only ever
wanted this Lucifer and HDR this scene
in Close Encounters of the Third Kind
like the whole segment is one of the
scariest scenes in any movie and it
always freaks me out as a kid at Best
Buy I have to expand
my HDR library alright folks we got some
yields rebuilding the library in HDR
some real deal holy yields Apollo 13
inception serenity Independence Day look
it's like this in looking for HDR I know
that if it was filmed in thirty
five-millimeter it'll look better
there's a lot of things filmed in
digital the masters are in two K whereas
thirty five-millimeter
you have much better resolution so I
just want to see how Independence Day
looks and it's cool well I could just
made excuses for Independence Day it's a
[ __ ] cool movie Schindler's List
Terminator 2 Judgment Day one of the
greatest movies of all time funny thing
is James Cameron used a lower quality
film
I guess when filming it so I want to see
how that looks the Martian and 2001 a
Space Odyssey because that will probably
blow my [ __ ] mind and how it looks
just in terms of film quality itself
probably be wait a minute wait for it
it'll be that's right out of this world
don't judge it was the thing to say at
the time
yeah
[ __ ] that's the best I've ever done at
that so at about midnight I just wanted
to pop in some 4k movies that I have I
just wanted to watch the beginning of
Bram Stoker's Dracula I ended up
watching the whole thing but I loved
Bram Stoker's Dracula it is legit really
good it's like it's my old man movie you
know that movie that makes me go I don't
make them like this anymore
so it got inspired to watch the making
of Bram Stoker's Dracula tonight and I
didn't know that all the special effects
were in-camera like black-and-white film
era effect techniques no CGI in-camera
effects like this they don't do that
anymore they didn't even do it when Bram
Stoker's Dracula was made that was like
going back Old Spice it's really
impressive you know my video on the Sony
spider-man marvel falling out ish
situation it's exporting right now and
there's already new news on it like I
knew there would be that's the thing
about talking about things like this you
have to be so fast because it's obsolete
in a second so hopefully it's
entertaining when it's obsolete in about
seven seconds so my video on the
spider-man Sony contract debacle is he
in is yeah at MCU versus Sony [ __ ]
anyhow if videos been up for about an
hour has a hundred thousand views all
people wanted was for me to talk about
that to review some matter anymore let's
just talk about movie news [ __ ] the
revenant in 4k it's one of the
best-looking movies I've seen like
period
that's the greatest clothing line it's
an allergy kind of day today sidenote my
friend Nathan and I hung out yesterday
with the Gauchos happy hour and some gin
and tonics it was a good time came back
and basically did a tech demo of the
protector their room because we both
like that kind of [ __ ] but I guess I've
reached the age where any drinks
whatsoever just give me headaches its
wine one glass two glasses I'm gonna try
one glasses usually you know if you're
drinking with a friend you have at least
two but yeah it's just like hey drink oh
headache deal with that [ __ ] now so
hopefully I still have one let's suck I
just it's not like I need drinks for a
good time or anything but it's like the
options nice side note the Amazon forest
is still burning so there is that I
don't mean to laugh it's kind of funny
how we're all talking about our day to
day [ __ ] because we can because it's
things that concern us but in the end
there's like big global stuff we all we
all see ourselves as a center of our own
universe - to an extent editing my video
in the mandalorian trailer last couple
days I've been in this last couple of
videos anyway which is like three days
I've been in this super weirdly chill
mood and I kind of like it it's like
Here I am in this video same way so I
hope you guys like it cuz I don't want
people to be like you've lost your
passion you've lost your energy [ __ ]
this this is depressing it's not sadness
it's just like how sweet hopefully you
like it I am apprehensive about Disney
bless them but DeLorean does look good
so the poster for episode 9 this is
episode 9 trailer day supposedly very
likely but the poster for episode I came
out to the joy of summon dismay of
others I have made a reference of it
looking like an animated series poster
except like your first client
it looks like the Clone Wars poster
that's what I thought it was thought
kylo ren's face shape I thought it was
like Count Dooku I just woken up and
it's like I didn't see the crossbar I'm
a lightsaber but it just it I thought it
was Clone Wars animation and I was like
oh no that's like episode nine titles
right there and everything okay that's
what it looks like to me so I guess the
rise of Skywalker trailers isn't
actually dropped till Monday let's go
back there so [ __ ] danger want to go
for a walk let's go for a walk so I
guess there's a trailer for the Breaking
Bad movie that drops it's a really
simple trailer but it's awesome so I
want to do a video on that what it's
this one dude on Instagram messages mean
he's like I'll be the Hunger fun to say
it but Breaking Bad movie trailer I was
like no you're the first so thank you
dude just watched the hateful eight
extended edition because it's in 4k in
HDR and I mean not only does it look
great that in the revenant I've got to
be the two best-looking movies I've seen
but the extended edition just it changes
the movie in a very good way because I
remember the flip the reveal and hateful
eight it felt like it came halfway
through the movie and the theatrical run
this one much later
I liked the theatrical run but I thought
this was better so I basically blocked
out my entire day to watch
better call Saul because I'd seen the
first couple seasons of better call Saul
and half a season three I didn't watch
the other half of season 3 I haven't
seen season four and then I had
mentioned in one of my videos that
Marvel up through the Thanos run up
through endgame it was like Breaking Bad
anything that comes after that it's like
better call Saul I wasn't insinuating
better call cells bad and it wasn't
insinuating that Marvel phase four is
going to be bad but I just remember
having that same feeling when better
call Saul was coming out like I don't
need to for it to be as good as Breaking
Bad but if it's if it's still great or
good I'm totally fine but no
expectations was my my point so that's
how I'm going into Marvel phase four it
turns out better call Saul is really
good
I don't can
as good as Breaking Bad but that's just
me but it does have some really great
stuff in there and some really great
characters so point of this rambling is
I'm like okay good to watch a seasoned
1/2 of better call Saul today or at
least as much as I possibly can and I
only had a couple episodes of season 3
left and she's a four is not on Netflix
so that that's that but it is on Amazon
Prime I could buy it for 20 bucks now I
kind of have to literally justing just
kind of thought while watching Rome I
know I was popped on episode 1 of season
1 of Rome and in Rome they kind of had
to speed up season 2 and bring it to an
end there was a lot they wanted to do
but if they brought Rome back now just
in cottony we just have it be with
Augustus Caesar ruling and just continue
on with the stories that were gonna tell
i totally be down with that you know you
can introduce new characters it's been
over 10 years now so wouldn't feel too
jarring yeah Rome under Augustus Caesar
let's just bring Rome back I think I
should
put another hundred hours into a fire MJ
once again that best buy Apocalypse Now
give anything Apocalypse Now deadline
and spawn is that actually a reference
or is it just saying hey we'll get ready
for your Apocalypse Now
not like Apocalypse Now point isn't for
Cal but you this looks awesome I almost
fell for a rookie mistake I was like oh
predator 20 bucks but no it's the
predator that is not the cast from
predator don't get that one joker
trailer dropped got a haircut it sliced
a little lay and I usually have the blue
background when talking about trailers
but there's this smudge on my collar
throughout the entire video for some one
reason due to uh for optical illusion a
red background made it less noticeable
than a blue background so I went with
red we've got to do it we got to do but
now that I mentioned the smudge on the
color you're never gonna unsee it in
that video sorry so an important element
to the home movie theater is the
curtains and these curtains are they're
soft and the more curtain ish I got
these curtains before this and they were
like they were kind of crusty like they
were dipped in wax or some it was
terrible so I returned those and got
these that are more curtain like I'll be
honest with you it just got done
watching the Star Wars prequels like all
of them back to I just watched them all
phantom and his attack of the clones or
then to the Sith and Revenge of the Sith
is like the one that I can watch you
know it's like the likable one the
goodtime no alcohol required one's a
very watchable movie despite you know
some of the issues I have with it but
the point is not Revenge of the set the
point is attack of the clones and
Phantom Menace because I'd always
thought attack of the clones was not as
good as Phantom Menace you know because
of all the love story [ __ ] that fell
flat in there but watching it Phantom
Menace is much more boring than attack
of the clones like phantom is one of
those movies if you like the prequel era
then there you are because that's the
joy that comes from it other than the
end fight there's the fact that you're
just there in the pre
valera but Attack of the Clones actually
has better pacing
despite the Anakin Padme stuff which is
still rough to watch but it does have
better pacing and that intrigue of like
ooh what's going on with the clones so
I'd actually say attack of the clones is
better than Phantom Menace now who knows
in about five years maybe I'll switch
back that's that's how movies are a few
years you can revisit movies and you
have a completely different take on it
it's the way it is actually it's not
just isolated to movies that's just how
things are in life but that's where I
stand now with those those two I don't
know it's just after the rise of
Skywalker trailer drop and I felt
nothing and I felt like an emotionless
husk I was like I think I should revisit
the prequels just to say maybe I should
just read review him I don't know this
is these my quick thoughts on it anyway
so there are reviews for Joker up now
people have already seen and reviewed
Joker I say I'm now gonna be inundated
with requests to review a movie I
haven't seen but fact is it was
watchable I haven't seen it good for
them
can't help but feel a little jealous
about that one hung out with my brother
today because I like hanging that was my
brother but the point of story is not me
hanging out with my brother poni story
is when he came over amazing spider-man
was on TV I was watching Amazing Spider
Man I don't hate that movie I enjoy it
whatever library is growing it now goes
from there to there so as you have seen
now in two journals LG sent me their
projector they wanted me to do a segment
my july journal which i did and they
wanted me to do a follow-up in the
August journal here they wanted me to
talk more about the stats but I didn't
know how to do it how to talk about you
know contrast ratio and things like that
in a way that's fun because I mean I
could just rattle off the steps like I
so this was this this has happened
that's not how I would do it in my
journal and I just I for the life of me
I was just like it's got to be fun it's
got to be a way I would do it and I have
fun doing it because this is the journal
it's supposed to be day-to-day fun
not just you know so static and and
binary so I defined a fun way to do it
though I recorded the 1080p blu-ray
version of a movie on my old projector
and the 4k HDR version on the new
projector and I filmed it on my phone
here so it's not like it's ripped from
the source but the color and contrast is
actually pretty accurately represented
so I'm telling you now like no that's if
it wasn't I feel like well just can't do
it I guess
so it actually is is pretty good for
bootleg so if I'm gonna do this and
we're gonna do it for science and I
actually did find some stuff that's
worth talking about it's actually really
cool and I want to share it with you um
so I'm gonna do that now and if I'm
gonna do it I'm gonna do it with the
movie I'm gonna use the thumb movie you
know the movie yet so of course this is
the movie one of the things I noticed
that you see right here the contrast in
the rocks and the concrete on the HDR
version the 4k version the white of the
rocks are much brighter and the shadows
are much darker whereas the 1080p
version kind of looks like just a cloudy
day it looks kind of muddy and grays
these are the details I never paid much
mind to until well now I'm paying mine
to it because you know comparison you
also see the deeper reds in the
telephone box and the masks to 1080p
versions orange-red the 4k versions red
orange and yes those two colors are
different and this is the crazy one
right here this is the one I was like
uh-oh so there's a color in that room I
had not noticed before is the bank vault
the bank vault has this greenish tint to
it that I've never noticed before the
blu-ray just kind of a white room is
it's a cream color at best the 4k
version clearly has a green tone in
there and it's not like the rest of the
footage is overrun with green but I
thought okay this projector does have a
red laser and a blue laser not a green
laser maybe it's trying to create green
but it's overcompensating for grain
making an artificial green an unnatural
green in a green room that's not
supposed to be a green room so I'll hook
this up to an HDR TV to see if the green
room still there and
there it is our friend in the green room
so it's just an HDR thing those are my
findings like I said for science because
it was kind of it was fun comparing the
two I know this month was very heavy on
the projector but I got the projector in
August so it was clearly the coolest
thing that happened to me that month so
you got a lot of projector this month
I'll still be messing with it next month
it probably didn't yeah this is fun so
thank you and if you can give this video
a like and pass it around and really
appreciate it because these I mean
they're not movie reviews they're not
why people really come to the channel
crazies and that's why I love you as
always if you like what you seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more yes that is the Ninja
Turtle series in its entirety so good I
almost push the camera
I got a transition with a puppy it's
tradition
[Music]